we're going to continue our chat with
west side stories ansel elgort on
location at his childhood theater camp
and he's about to show us around
but first he's going to show me some
moves
and then it goes a little something like
this take a look
will you show me around your school yeah
i have to show you something first
though while we're here show me first
these red ladders
this is part of the our time cabaret the
hour time cabaret was like the ultimate
honor if you were in the our time
cabaret it meant that you could sing you
could dance and you clearly loved
performing
i have to show you the dance from our
time cabaret this is the famous dance
it's called
what a country okay so like you lift one
foot and you
and you shuffle the other so like do you
like how like the other leg just won't
get up right now i'm like okay
yeah and now we go to the right
and now we go twice to the left
did i tell you or did i tell you
i can't be cool okay okay by the way you
just met the real me
make your funniest face
that's your funniest face
there we go okay yours
yeah you've done more comedies than you
missed you're the dancer i'm the court
jester but there's a place for both of
us where should we go we'll just take a
walk around the camp right so natalie
portman went here robert downey jr yeah
uh beanie feldstein yep yeah we were we
were in the cabaret together we were
doing that
dance together
wow i love this room i love this place
this was the boy's dormitory can you
guess what the name is what is it
it's called barrymore
don't play with me it's serious it's
called barrymore
and i never put the even the two and two
together but it's actually apparently
it's named after you
and that nuts
that's crazy right but there's no girls
allowed in barrymore so you're not
allowed to go inside
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
i mean
i'm sorry but like the steven connection
and the fact that you were in barrymore
not nuts and we're here together
this was the first stage that i was on
here um i was in
uh once upon a mattress
and
joseph and the amazing technicolor
dreamcoat yes
and it was called the kitty show because
kitty yeah because when you were the the
this show had kids playing leads
then when you got to the other theaters
if you were like 11 years old you
wouldn't play lead
usually so how old are you here
11 and 12.
and then when you're 12 you go over
there and you do your west side story on
that stage yes so that was my first show
out of the kitty show how did you meet
violetta which by the way just sounds so
shakespearean and perfect where did you
know the most beautiful name ever right
it is
um we met in high school so wait god how
long have you been dating almost 10
years yeah we've known each other for 10
years
i love this how does that not become a
rock in your life how's that not so such
a grounding force i mean
is it a grounding force definitely yeah
so what does she say if you get like
egoy she yeah she definitely keeps it
real with me
she's tough on me
that's good that's good
look at this wow oh my god i remember
like all these people why don't we do
headshots anymore absolutely
remember we used to go to like dry
cleaners and diners and there were
headshots everywhere wow we used to have
an epic ping-pong rivalry me and brian
you did
who won
uh you know it was pretty even that's
why i was a good rivalry oh look there i
am my dad took that photo by the way
that's your ann solo like on spotify
picture
your dad took that yep we took it yeah
in brooklyn when i was like uh maybe 20.
at night time you had kind of like free
time you could kind of just roam around
and all the rooms were open see they
have pianos in every room so i'd come
and play piano sing i heard you say that
you wish you could be like prince so you
could just pick up any instrument and
play it yeah you know but that's
it's he worked on that for sure
[Music]
this uses a tap dance in here it's good
sound
good light right
[Music]
yeah this was a makeup room
[Music]
this is the ultimate perfect last
question
should i
would you recommend it
to other kids to come here yeah
yeah i'm very grateful for my time here
and
of all good memories even the
you know rejection and all that kind of
stuff it's like it all sets you up for
real life and even if you don't get the
role you want you make it work and you
put your heart and soul into it and
all the people you meet here and
everyone's so passionate and yeah so i
definitely recommend it i love coming
here
[Applause]
my goodness west side story is in
theaters this friday december 10th and
may i just say
that this is so much more than a film it
is the humanity and the revelation and
the coming together that we all need
i can't wait for everyone to see it
[Music]